[Music]
hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
the Caucasian stallion stallion still
white I'm Walter 'then AZ heard you're
watching rocky for this time rocky for
we did rocky one together yeah because
you're a big fan of rocky maybe watch
rocky two and three to prep to get into
four cuz you haven't seen those easy I
hadn't seen those either but I just
heard that rocky 4 was such a mess or
like not a mess but just really
different everyone loves it ironically
and on ironically I say okay so you did
a fan scription on this yeah so we have
a new show on channel awesome called fan
scripts and we get to change things in
movies and like make our own version of
what would have played out after that
big change so I made one for Rocky floor
for called what if Apollo Creed close
your ears did it die in rocky for people
seem to enjoy for the most part so go
ahead and check it out and suggest
things that you want to see next time
you also wrote out predictions for me I
did that was the first episode ever with
predictions I also went down a few notes
for Rocky's two and three I want to say
rocky choose my favorite that's my
favorite as well it's so damn good one
was so like rah and two is just like the
perfection they just found it sorry is
really good too but to just has such a
good heart string moment absolutely twos
like the formula movie like that's the
first formula version that they kind of
set all the Rocky's after that sort of
I'm that kind of map out you know yeah
to is just amazing I love every single
second of rocky tube I miss Adrian's
pyramid head but she looks like George
Washington's or something zooming in
it's pretty great are these new bricks
whenever he's checking out a house like
it is rocky always is it's gonna be map
in that place out I only wrote two
things for rocky three and that's I have
the tiger which I was gonna sing but
I'll spare saw and cropped up on the
beach dance shorty short shorts like
that's what we got going on
I really enjoyed them and now I'm really
excited to jump into rocky 4 because I
hear it's just I know about the robot
okay that's like all the way it's the
biggest spoiler I'm really excited to do
it
alright I'm excited to anytime I watch
the rocking that I'm excited especially
experiencing it through new people's
eyes snap with me sure I'm in the intro
- yeah so we're snapping to both of us
all right here we go one two three
[Music]
okay what did you think of the magnum
opus okay okay
I'm gonna compare it to fallout 76 what
follows in v6 there's just giant like
controversy around it right now because
it's fallout there's some really good
aspects to fallout to it but it's just
so different from fallout as well people
are a nice felt that so much watching
this like I really liked it and I got
like great aspects from the first three
but also there's a robot yes different
enough for you like it was good but it
was different sure I get you yeah I mean
that's always been my biggest kind of
complaint with the movie it's my least
favorite Rocky movie but as I said in
many videos and including a few on here
that I will take this over any other non
Rocky movie that's how much of a
sickness I have this movie made the most
out of any of the movies including now
for inflation any of the other you know
the Creed movies are rocking about boy
it's still the highest-grossing movie
for the franchise and really got a lot
of people interested it was at the
height of the Cold War in 1985 it was
Russia the Soviet Union and America the
United States of America so it was I
guess an appropriate time to put that
out but it just doesn't feel like a
Rocky movie that much to me I think the
first three do such a good job with the
characters and that's what draws me in I
always avoided these movies because I
thought that it was gonna be like this
just two hours of fighting and it's not
not at all and I love that about one two
and three and this is less character II
like way less character II and a lot
more about the fighting fighting is
really really well done and really good
well choreographed the fact that they
kill off Apollo Creed with just such
like a throwaway like in the first 15
minutes like the robot is in it more
than he is robots get some more screen
time with Apollo dude I hate that first
note that I wrote down for rocky for is
cool cool businesses use oh there's a
robot
what businesses usual happy birthday
Polly
happy birthday Polly big robots ooh
yeah it is very large robot I knew I
knew about it but I imagine it was like
this small little like room oh nothing
like quite like seeing a giant robot in
a Rocky movie so I can't agree with that
I thought I was gonna like the robot I
thought you liked the robot Rana Cleo's
gonna be like this is yeah yeah but I it
was too much and when the robot changes
voices and it's like in love with Polly
it's my girl robot ball no one is gonna
get this reference but Drago reminds me
of congressman Murray from parks and
recreation with his room hunt like
acting Drago was like what did I say so
you look like a Ken doll people didn't
catch I've never heard that comparison
before but accurate also I thought he
looks like a prettier meaner Val Kilmer
ah yes that's a great compare you know
era Russians were all over the place as
villains in the 80s and now that just a
face and then Apollo dies I hate that he
dies like that if you're gonna kill him
kill him but don't do it in like a
throwaway stupid fight that didn't mean
anything that's so much more going on
with rocking in Apollo's relationship
that we didn't get to see you know turn
into you know more stuff with Rocky
fighting and there was more story there
as you can see in my fans good food
there's so many montages the first one
is so it's really nice I really like
seeing all awesome clips from one two
and three no easy way out yeah but like
why I saw Rocky three first when I was
eight and I saw four shortly after that
those the ones I saw first the most
often so then seeing that there are all
these clips from the other movies like
it's a whole nother world almost I mean
like the you know going from - because
we watched two three
or you could see the huge difference oh
that's the real rock you what are we
watching looks like I like the idea of
that of like seeing how far we've come
but it goes on for like three minutes
yeah they play the full song one then we
get a huge fighting montage and then
Adrienne comes to Russia and then
another huge fucking montage Adrienne is
just like a pause in the montage to the
miss you even more true more training
though I love this training montage all
of them one through four have been just
knockout awesome training montages I
wrote that it was a big missed
opportunity for him not to fight the
robot drive over Cesaro Morocco catches
the robot kissing oh my god it will
never get old to see rocky like prevail
in this impossible fight I will watch
Rocky Balboa climb the ladder of success
any day you gotta watch the next four
now can I finish out the series after we
watched one like two years ago I was
like I can't wait to watch their
goodness I would do this immediately I
wrote that the end is pretty
heavy-handed really fucking the
translation is pretty great I don't know
if it's accurate I don't speak Russian
but let me know what you did my favorite
I think part of the end and my favorite
I mean really this is what we're doing a
swim that one last guy goes is it silly
five is back in the rocky world well so
rocky five is universally pretty much
everyone least favorite Rocky movie it
didn't make a lot of money at the box
office it's the only one that didn't
turn a profit a lot of people really
hate it that's why he wanted to come
back years later with Rocky Balboa which
is Rocky six in 2006 that came out yeah
I'm too kind of right this
and ended on a positive note but as we
know Rocky Balboa was not the last to
practice movie as Creed went on to make
it even better movies yeah one question
about 5,000 yeah how many robots are
there
what were your predictions I said that
you would love the music I think love is
a strong word I definitely liked them
okay so kind of I put that you would
love the eighties necessary date es ATS
within ATS right in like a fun way not
like I love it it's better than the
other movies because yeah I did love the
87 okay so that's I wrote that you would
think it's goofy yeah I put I don't know
I don't think it's one's right I put
that you would think that it's both of
the worst and the best one I don't know
why but that does sound like no no I'm
just the worst I think it's the worst I
work through the more the worst one I've
only seen one through four but so far
four is definitely the worst support
that you would love Drago and his wife's
hair both of their hair yeah because
they basically have the same haircut
yeah they do
I liked it on her more than him but yes
yeah and the last one I was pretty much
for sure I kind of knew this was gonna
happen but both of the fights were rough
to watch for you so I have a new rating
system where I give 0 out of 10
hair flip oh and I think okay so I just
gave battleship two out of ten hair flow
give this six out of ten hair plugs okay
where I would give to rocky to if I were
doing Justin episode brush to I would
give that ten out of ten hair flips so
I'm gonna thank you so much for watching
I will see you all next week
bad because I tried to didn't slow down
his talking so they tried to make it
match up to his slow motion moving so it
was like
[Music]
[Applause]
you